bonsoir à tous il est 20 heures voici
les titres de l'actualité de ce vendredi
nous tenterons tout d'abord d'en savoir
plus sur la situation au tibet les
autorités chinoises ont une nouvelle
fois réprimées aujourd'hui violemment
les manifestations
on parle désormais de plusieurs morts à
cinq mois des jeux olympiques la
question des droits de l'homme est de
plus en plus pesant que pour pékin après
48 heures de recherche les deux
adolescents qui avaient été portées
disparues dans un village de corrèze ont
été aujourd'hui retrouvé mort au fond
d'un lac
c'est un accident de canoë qui serait à
l'origine de leur noyade
les français aiment rouler au gazole 75%
des voitures neuves vendues sont des
diesels la raison essentielle le moindre
coût du carburant
mais le paradoxe est là les prix de
l'essence et du gazole sont en passe
d'être identiques
nous verrons pour toi c'est la grande
pagaille pour les automobilistes cette
fois concernant le permis à points avec
cette question savez vous vraiment
combien de points il vous reste sur le
vôtre
eh bien vous le verrez ce soir que la
mise à jour ressemble parfois à une
loterie
enfin du rugby avec la finale en quelque
sorte du tournoi des six nations qui se
jouera demain à cardiff la france
rencontre le pays de galles qui rêve
d'un grand chelem les bleus de leur côté
devront s'imposer largement pour
remporter le tournoi
merci d'être avec nous et on commence ce
journal par la situation au tibet après
plusieurs jours de manifestations et
d'intervention de la police chinoise au
sein de la province
les affrontements ont pris une nouvelle
dimension ces dernières heures difficile
d'avoir des informations très détaillées
mais on évoque désormais plusieurs morts
et de nombreux blessés notamment à
lhassa la capitale historique ce soir
pékin accuse le dalaï lama d'être je
cite à l'origine de ces troubles
le chef spirituel toujours en exil lui
appelle les autorités chinoises à cesser
leur répression philippe rochot tout a
commencé par une manifestation sur le
parcours du pélérinage de l'aca seul
témoignage dans un tibet où les
journalistes sont très contrôlés ces
photos montrant plusieurs centaines de
moines
brandissant le drapeau tibétain interdit
ici la police a dû se barricader
derrière un écran de boucliers pour
éviter les jets de pierres et la riposte
est tiré en l'air mais on parle de morts
et de nombreux blessés
des touristes français raconte nous
avons fait là est la manifestation
l'équipe nous avait dit tu te vers
l'hôtel
alors on a couru on a couru avec lui et
qu'ils allaient les soldats qui sont
venus les militaires quoi et on a
commencé un temps d écouter tiré puis
nous sommes rentrés tout c'est à l'hôtel
en temps normal ce quartier de lhassa où
ont éclaté les manifestations est
parcouru par des milliers de pèlerins
qui d'état qui seront autant que ça crée
du jogging après avoir marché en se
prosternant pendant parfois plusieurs
mois un lieu symbolique pour demander au
pouvoir chinois plus de liberté pour le
tibet en cet anniversaire du soulèvement
de 1959 une crise la répression ne cesse
d'augmenter à l'intérieur du tibet a dit
nice les tibétains sont marginalisés
deviennent d'une minorité dans leur
propre pays ils sont considérés comme
des citoyens de deuxième classe août
lisbet la communauté tibétaine dans le
monde entier comme ce soir népal saisi
l'occasion des jeux olympiques pour
demander plus d'autonomie voire même
l'indépendance du tibet le pouvoir
chinois accusent le dalaï lama d'avoir
fomenté ces troubles les plus violents
depuis le soulèvement de 1989 et une
chose est sûre ce soir pékin entend bien
ne pas communiquer sur ce dossier là le
silence est la règle c'est ce qu'a pu
constater notre correspondant pascal
golomer il est dans la capitale chinoise
ce soir hier officiels chinois
strictement contrôlée par le
gouvernement n'évoque absolument pas les
violences qui ont lieu aujourd'hui à la
salle comme elle n'avait pas évoqué
d'ailleurs les différentes
manifestations qui se sont déroulées
depuis le début de la semaine à la fois
en chine et en inde
silence radio donc à l'exception de
l'agencé officielle chine nouvelle
l'agencé xinhua qui évoque ce soir le
dalaï lama comme étant le responsable
des troubles le fomenteur des troubles
qui sont déroulés à lhassa quant aux
télévisions étrangères qui sont
diffusées dans certaines résidences et
dans certains grands hôtels
à pékin comme dans les grandes villes
chine bien dès qu'elle évoque le sujet
l'écran et devient un écran noir comme
c'est le cas d'ailleurs dès qu'un sujet
sensible est évoqué quant aux autorités
elles elles sont entièrement focalisée
sur l'assemblée nationale populaire qui
est le grand événement politique de
l'année ici en chine et qui se déroulent
encore à pékin le tibet est évoquée
certes mais certainement pas à propos
des manifestations c'est toujours en
termes très positif le tibet qui est un
sujet sensible
toute l'année en chine mais qu'il est
encore encore plus aujourd'hui
surtout à quelques semaines des jeux
olympiques alors on l'a dit ces
manifestations font suite à un appel du
dalaï lama qui est en exil depuis 50 ans
que craignent désormais les autorités
chinoises à cinq mois du lancement des
jeux olympiques c'est que l'événement
sportif serbe désormais de caisse de
résonance à toutes les revendications
liées aux droits de l'homme le point
avec christelle bertrand christian
hottin et virginie travers un seul monde
un seul rêve officiellement toute la
chine fait bloc derrière le slogan des
jeux olympiques
officiellement aussi ses apprentis
supporters progresse et pourront bientôt
donner l'exemple dans les stades
un seul monde un seul rêve sorties de
chine
la phrase a de plus en plus de mal à
convaincre les défenseurs des droits de
l'homme première a lancé la contestation
l'actrice mia farrow qui frappe sans
réponse à la porte de la délégation
chinoise aux nations unies et puis c'est
le coup de théâtre mise en scène par
steven spielberg le réalisateur
américain a décidé de boycotter les jeux
olympiques alors qu'il devait en être le
conseiller artistique pour les
cérémonies la semaine dernière à la
chanteuse bjork protestent en public et
pas devant n'importe lequel celui de
shanghai en chine
la chanteuse appel à l'indépendance du
tibet sur internet plusieurs sites
français appellent au boycott et dans
les forums les discussions sont vives
reporter sans frontières a imprimé ses
t-shirts ou les anneaux olympiques
laisse place à des menottes
un symbole qui contribue à mettre la
pression sur les autorités chinoises si
rien n'est fait du côté de la communauté
un des seuls ils écraseront une fois de
plus le mouvement de contestation de
tibétains si maintenant il y a une vraie
mobilisation du côté des occidentaux
ils trouveront une solution pourquoi
parce qu'ils ont absolument envie que
les jeux olympiques se passe bien un
seul monde un seul rêve
ce dissident chinois n'a jamais cru aux
slogans officiels
rhodia a été arrêté en septembre pour
incitation à la subversion
en fait ils estiment que pékin n'a
jamais respecté ses engagements en
faveur des droits de l'homme pour
obtenir les jeux olympiques
il est jugé mardi prochain encore un
événement qui risque de faire réagir la
communauté internationale enfant je vous
le disais en titre le village de les
stars en corrèze est donc sous le choc
le corps des deux adolescents de la
commune qui était recherché depuis 48
heures ont été retrouvé dans un lac à
proximité de leur domicile selon les
premiers éléments de l'enquète kevin et
vincent âgés de 13 et 15 ans se serait
noyé après que leurs canoës et chavirer
carmaux et j il avait embarqué sur ce
canoë dans une zone interdite à la
navigation
les corps de kevin 13 ans et vincent 15
ans ont été retrouvés au fond de ce lac
artificiel un bassin de retenue d'eau
situé près d'un barrage leur embarcation
a chaviré à 50 mètres du bord pour une
raison inconnue
cette table ronde a lâché deux lâchers
d'eau d'edf
donc il faudra qu'on examine mais ça ça
va faire l'objet d'investigations
complémentaires pour visualiser quel est
l'impact des lâchers d'eau à ce
niveau-là du plan d'eau les deux
collégiens en portaient des vêtements
larges ils ont été happés vers le fond
dans une eau à 6 degrés le plus jeune ne
savait pas nager
aucun des deux ne portait de gilet de
sauvetage depuis leur disparition
mercredi une centaine de gendarmes
étaient mobilisés
tout le village voulait encore y croire
tout le monde en parle tout le monde et
tout le monde s est dit au monde
connaissent et ses enfants si j'étais au
collège de treignac qu'ils étaient bons
alors là ça c'est sûr le reste des
problèmes de navigation et de lâcher
d'eau la seule certitude est que les
enfants n'ont pas été agressé le médecin
légiste est formel il s'agit bien d'une
noyade accidentelle en grande bretagne
en revanche c'est un épilogue heureux
que vient de connaître une affaire de
disparition d'enfants une fillette de 9
ans était recherché depuis maintenant 24
jours la police les médias et la
population s'étaient mobilisés afin de
retrouver la trace de la petite shannon
qui avait disparu après une sortie
scolaire et bien les enquêteurs l'ont
retrouvé aujourd'hui au domicile d'un
homme de 39 ans le lit de mort nés
pendant trois semaines sa mère a vécu un
enfer sans aucune nouvelle de sa fille
shannon âgé de 9 ans
les dernières images de la fillette
avait été enregistrée par une caméra de
surveillance alors qu'elle se rendait à
la piscine depuis rien et aujourd'hui la
délivrance shannon a été retrouvée
vivante
elle est sous la protection de la police
les voisins de la famille exulte on n'a
jamais perdu espoir
jamais tous les gens du quartier qui se
sont mobilisés n'ont jamais perdu
tu vois je présentais le pire ce matin
j'ai même dit à ma mère que ça
s'annonçait mal
et deux heures après j'apprends qu'elle
ait été retrouvée saine et sauve je sais
pas comment réagir si on doit se sentir
malade pour ce qu'elle a enduré ou s'il
faut se réjouir et courir dans la rue
pendant trois semaines la police avait
mené l'une des plus importantes
opérations de recherche jamais
entreprise dans la région shannon a été
retrouvé dans une petite ville juste à
deux kilomètres de son domicile
c'est au cours d'une fouille dans une
maison que la fillette a été découverte
dissimulés dans la structure d'un canapé
lit l'homme qui habitait âgé de 39 ans
est soupçonné de l'enlèvement et a été
immédiatement arrêté on revient en
france avec la colère des familles des
victimes du crash du mont sainte-odile
16 ans après la mort de 87 passagers
d'un airbus a320 ils attendaient une
nouvelle fois beaucoup de l'arrêt de la
cour d'appel de colmar aujourd'hui mais
une nouvelle fois ils n'ont pas obtenu
gain de cause
pire la justice est même revenu sur la
responsabilité civile d'airbus pourtant
reconnue en première instance reportage
à stéphanie la fuente et jean-pierre
pasteur ils ont attendu ce jugement
pendant plus de 16 ans mais après la
lecture du délibéré
la solennité cède sa place à la colère
et aux larmes
complément plaques' via personne
personne ces salades ou utiliser de la
france est derrière moi
la route a derrière moi et je voudrais
que toutes les races les coûte tout de
suite
la cour d'appel a relaxé les six
prévenus et a écarté la responsabilité
civile d'airbus reconnue en première
instance
et comme un dernier coup de massue la
cour a annulé les 500000 euros
d'indemnisation accordé aux victimes
pour frais d'avocat les familles ont
tout perdu
c'est pas maintenant qu'on a perdu c'est
le 20 janvier 92 et les responsabilités
ou les causes de l'accident ne sont pas
connues
ni les expertises ni les débats n'ont
permis d'établir une cause directe entre
des erreurs de pilotage ou de guidage et
l'accident c'est pourquoi les cadres de
l'aviation civile d'air inter et le
contrôleur aérien ont été relaxés quant
à la faute de négligence reconnu à
bernard ziegler le concepteur de l'a320
elle n'a pas été retenu cette fois
airbus est aussi blanches et l'honneur
airbus est entièrement le havre
la catastrophe du mont sainte-odile
s'est produite le 20 janvier 1992 elle
avait fait 87 morts les victimes vont se
pourvoir en cassation
pour elle le long chemin de croix
judiciaire ne s'arrêtera donc pas à
colmar justice toujours jérôme kerviel
devra attendre mardi pour savoir s'il
retrouvera la liberté on pensait que la
chambre d'instruction de la cour d'appel
rendra sa décision aujourd'hui mais à la
mise en délibéré le trader soupçonné de
falsifications au dépens de la société
générale et depuis le vie février à la
maison d'arrêt de la santé à paris et en
prison l'homme a choisi de se faire ici
encore extrêmement discret julien
beaumont fanny stenneler déjà 36 jours
derrière les barreaux
jérôme kerviel est en détention
provisoire à la prison de la santé
seul traitement de faveur une cellule
dans le quartier vip
mais selon son conseiller en
communication le trader se méfie des
autres détenus de sortir de sortir en
promenade
parce qu'il peut il craint que des des
photos volées viennent être être publiés
sur lui en promenade
quelle saison voici la seule série de
photos que jérôme kerviel accepte de
voir circuler
celle d'un homme confiant un homme qui a
coûté 5 milliards d'euros à la société
générale
kerviel a pourtant toujours affirmé ne
pas vouloir être le bouc émissaire de la
société générale
une suite à ses propos tenus en garde à
vue il est décrit sa vision des salles
de marché tant que nous gagnons et que
ça ne se voit pas trop et que ça arrange
on ne dit rien s'agit-il des dérives
d'un homme seul ou bien des défaillances
de tout un système
c'est ce que l' enquête tente de
déterminer hier lors d'une confrontation
avec ses anciens supérieurs
le trader a reconnu avoir placé quatre
cents fois la mise maximum autorisé par
sa banque
loin du dossier judiciaire la société
générale se renfloue elle vient
d'augmenter son capital de 5,5 milliards
d'euros
le marché commence à se rassurer
l'action depuis la crise a repris 6
euros
cette affaire passionne voici le premier
des quatre livres à paraître sur le
dossier mais personne pour l'instant n'a
recueilli les confidences complète du
trader le cv de jérôme kerviel lui aussi
intéresse un expert informatique lui en
effet proposé un poste dès sa sortie de
prison
impossible de savoir s'il retrouvera son
dernier salaire de traders
cent mille euros par an avec les primes
parlons d'un procès maintenant qui se
déroulait à aix en provence et qui s'est
terminé hier en l'absence de l'un des
principaux accusés car l'homme s'est
tout simplement volatilisé le jour du
verdict francis mariani membre d'un gang
bastiais que l'on appelle à la brise de
mer a finalement été condamné par défaut
pour l'assassinât en 2001 d'un
nationaliste corse retour sur cette
affaire avec aurélia guillemin
le verdict est tombé tard hier soir mais
l'un des principaux accusés n'étaient
plus dans le box pour l'entendre
francis mariani figure du gang la brise
de mer rentrer en corse la veille aurait
raté l'avion du retour il n'est pas
réapparu depuis
nadine téléphonie en maintenant que vous
êtes il dit je ne savais pas où ci va
arriver le président ce qu'on va faire
du monde c'est green ou non celui qui
était reparti je sais pas sept ans de
prison par défaut pour francis mariani
15 ans pour son fils jacques les deux
seuls reconnus coupables de l'assassinât
du nationaliste nicolas montigny a battu
à bastia en septembre 2001 les pilotes
d'un procès tumultueux pour la cour
d'assises des bouches du rhône grand
banditisme et nationalisme la justice
qui redoutait des pressions avaient
délocalisé la sphère feng perdu la
semaine dernière trois hommes ont même
tenté d'intimider de jurer jusque devant
chez eux
il est prévisible et pour fait ce que il
aurait fallu ces injures et de
magistrats une cour de magistrats
professionnels dans les très sensible de
grand banditisme
j'ai dit que ces méthodes constituent
est à mes yeux un cancer mais en même
temps on ne peut pas faire payer le prix
de ses agissements à les supposer avérés
aux accusés qui sont dans le box
à 59 ans francis mariani et donc en
cavale pour la justice presque une
habitude pour celui qui en juin 2001
s'évader de la prison de borgo en corse
par la grande porte
grâce à un faux fax ordonnant sa
libération et si le prix du gazole
dépasser bientôt celui de l'essence
en tout cas il s'en rapproche à grands
pas en moyenne seulement 12 centimes
d'euros de différence à la pompe et vous
êtes très nombreux à vous intéresser
cette évolution tout simplement parce
qu'en france 75% des voitures neuves
vendues aujourd'hui sont des diesels le
diesel moins cher qui devient plus cher
voyons pourquoi avec caroline thébaux et
guillaume michel plus que 10 centimes de
différence cet après midi entre le
gazole et le sans plomb 95
l'écart se réduit et certains
automobilistes s'interroge sur l'intérêt
d'une voiture diesel
j'ai une autre voiture qui est à essence
ces pratiques global bah je vais acheter
parce qu'à l'époque c'était un père
usant de rouler en diesel
aujourd'hui pour la question sur la
prochaine voiture car le prix du gazole
ne cesse d'augmenter
quand on regarde les tarifs hors taxes
il est même bien plus cher que le sans
plomb et cela risque de s'accentuer
ce phénomène là il est dû simplement au
fait que la demande en gazole continue
de croître alors que la demande en
essence elles chutent déséquilibre donc
entre l'offre et la demande
car côté production sur 100 litres de
pétrole brut
les industriels arrive à fabriquer 32
litres de gazole pas plus le reste c'est
de l'essence du fuel
or côté consommation la demande explose
aujourd'hui trois voitures neuves sur
quatre rouleaux gazole des véhicules
diesel qui malgré la hausse des prix
reste économique
ils consomment moins et comme il rejette
moins de co2 ils bénéficient souvent
d'une prime à l'achat
même s'il est plus cher à l'achat il
faut compter 1500 et 2000 euros de plus
pour aller un véhicule diesel mais du
coup grâce au bonus qui équipe l de 750
euros
sur véhicules notamment les sites al
youm et là du coup c'est relativement
vite rentabilisé un bonus écologique qui
dope les ventes depuis le début de
l'année la consommation de gazole n'est
donc pas prête de baisser
granger on le sait l'objet de toutes les
attentions gandrange c'est cette usine
en moselle que la direction du groupe
arcelormittal souhaite amputée de la
moitié des effectifs
on se souvient la visite du président de
la république au mois de février depuis
plusieurs plans de sauvetage sont à
l'étude et aujourd'hui c'est bernard
thibault pour la cgt qui faisait le
déplacement
nous étions avec lui reportage sophie
brune alain duban capuron tôt ce matin
en gare de metz bernard thibault vient
rencontrer sa base et appréhender le
climat social direction quand drange
nicolas sarkozy s'est rendu le mois
dernier alors que la syrie est menacée
il ne suffit pas d'appareil de fair lady
school il faut des actes concrets de la
marde des responsables politiques à tous
les niveaux sur place comité d'accueil
réduit mais chaleureux bonjour bonjour
le secrétaire général de la cgt et vise
en premier les revendications des
salariés auprès de la direction
pas de caméra donc mais notre micro a pu
enregistrer l'avertissement lancé par
bernard thibault arcelormittal nous
serons de ce salon suivre la situation
indique que ce n'est pas uniquement une
visite ponctuelle en tout cas pour ce
qui nous concerne
pour ma part dans cette usine du numéro
un mondial de l'acier bernard thibault
commente aussi une autre actualité de la
métallurgie les caisses noires du mad
money de lui elle rappelé il est
particulièrement scandaleux que des
entreprises aient détourné de l'argent
produit du travail des métallurgistes à
des fins anti syndicale
de retour à metz avec les militants du
département
le leader syndical fait passer un
dernier message à deux jours des
municipales
naturellement j'entends dire de la part
notamment du premier ministre non
seulement qu'il faut rester sur le même
cap
mais qu'il faut garder le même rythme si
on écoute pas davantage le pays je pense
que c'est source de blocage premier
risque de blocage la réforme des
retraites la cgt appelle déjà à
manifester le 29 mars prochain politique
avec les municipales et les deux images
du jour il ya ceux qui rêvent d'être élu
et puis il ya ceux qui ont déjà pris
leur place dans leur fauteuil de maire
ça a été le cas aujourd'hui d'alain
juppé à bordeaux qui avait remporté
l'élection dès le premier tour dimanche
dernier
mais également de françois rebsamen pour
le parti socialiste cette fois à dijon
on le sait depuis dimanche dernier donc
le second tour des élections pourrait
coûter plusieurs bastions la majorité
présidentielle jetant un coup d'oeil sur
cette carte de france des points chauds
ni retrouve toulouse strasbourg
périgueux mais également amiens reims
quand des villes qui seront regardées à
la loupe des 20 heures dimanche
parmi ces villas en jeu il ya aussi
marseille quelle sera la couleur
politique de la ville voilà une question
qui reste toujours sans réponse
on le sait jean claude gaudin est en
difficulté et le match sera serré
reportage stéphane lippinois et benoît
jourdain gagner plus les jours passent
plus il y croit très distancés au début
de la campagne à présent coude à coude
avec le maire sortant jean noël guérini
entrevoit sa victoire je sens un
mouvement mondial candidature à notre
équipe par rapport au projet que nous
présentons m'assieds et qu'il est en
train de se produire
jean claude gaudin lui n'entend pas
vacillé lâcher prise en visite sur la
canebière il abat ses cartes il égrène
comme un chapelet les réalisations de
ces demandes ont fait de fractures droit
aux affaires théâtre on a mis les
pompiers on a mené le train anglais on a
fait beaucoup de choses à trois jours du
match du second tour chacun présente les
supporters jean noël guérini reçoit le
renfort du lyonnais gérard collomb
fraîchement réélu dimanche dernier comme
il est sûr d'être élu un qu'il voulait
me faire plaisir
il a dit je vais faire un peu de
publicité pour gérard collomb
cette semaine jean claude gaudin lui a
brandi une lettre de soutien de nicolas
sarkozy mais dans cette campagne il a
surtout joué à plein sur son image
chacun sait que je me suis battu toute
ma vie que pour cette ville que j'avais
rêvé d'un toner j'ai pas tout fait j'ai
pas de baguette magique mais j'ai essayé
de transformer cette ville et je
voudrais continuer on lui dit stop et
souhaite brillamment l'alternance la
gauche tenait meeting hier soir la
mairie ump va si elle n'est pas encore
tombée la faire chuter c'est le travail
que nous devons faire coup de rame à
gauche ou à droite
la parole est désormais aux marseillais
s'occuper des riches et des pauvres je
venais quand j'entendais réuni quitter
marseille talent il n'a jamais dit une
seule fois les marseillais social à
marseille le score du second tour
s'annonce serré très serré plus que
jamais chaque bulletin contre alors on a
d'abord entendu parler de remaniements
au lendemain de ces élections voici venu
maintenant la notion de petits
ajustements
c'est en tout cas ce que l'on évoque
dans l'entourage du président de la
république on retrouve michaël darmon à
l'elysée bonsoir michael alors est ce
que vous en savez un peu plus sur cette
notion d' ajustement alors écoutez le
cadre général a été fixé par nicolas
sarkozy pour ses réglages ajustements
dont qui concerne le gouvernement
premier principe les ministres ne
bougeront pas il s'agira essentiellement
donc de changement au sein des
secrétaires d'état avec des nouveaux
secrétaires d'état qui pourrait faire
donc la réapparition le grand paris
l'aménagement du territoire le numérique
peut être l'emploi ce n'est pas sûr il
faudra également remplacé christian
estrosi
à l'outre-mer qui démissionnera s'il est
élu à nice et la réaliser on dit que le
profil c'est bien sûr très politique et
très proche pour ce dossier sensible et
consultations vont durer encore tout le
week end et seront ajustées en fonction
des résultats
mais quel est finalement c'est l'équipe
de communication de l'elysée qui
pourrait le plus changé finalement oui
c'est peut-être là effectivement le
changement le plus visible porte parole
à tout terrain à l'américaine vous savez
qui est installé depuis le début et qui
est un peu le symbole cette
hyperprésidence
eh bien il a été décidé donc hier qu'il
devrait donc s'arrêter et donc laisser
la place à un goût un pôle de
communication sur les affaires inter
d'intérieur est également un pôle donc
pour la communication extérieure la
diplomatie qui se devrait être attribué
à un conseiller diplomatique david
martinon le porte-parole actuelle il
pourrait continuer sa carrière de
diplomate vraisemblablement à new york
c'est donc le principal changement que
l'on voit donc s'annoncer également un
changement sera effectué dans l'équipe
qui gère les relations avec les élus
notamment avec le parlement tous ces
signes la montre qu'en fait
l'hyperprésidence pour se changer et que
nicolas sarkozy amorce le seul vrai
changement
après ces municipales celui de son
propre style merci michael et la
campagne donc officiel se termine ce
soir à à minuit pour ces municipales la
fin du sommet européen de bruxelles les
vingt-sept se sont mis d'accord pour le
lancement de l'union de la méditerranée
un projet cher au président sarkozy mais
qui a fait l'objet d'un amendement par
rapport à ses ambitions premières
l'union européenne entend en tout cas
créer un partenariat avec les pays du
sud
un partenariat dont on connaîtra les
contours à paris en juillet prochain en
iran 44 millions d'électeurs étaient
appelés aujourd'hui à renouveler leur
parlement
un test de popularité en quelque sorte
pour le président ahmadinejad
il souhaite que les conservateurs
poursuivent leur domination à
l'assemblée les réformateurs quant à eux
ont déjà dénoncé quelques irrégularités
dans un scrutin qui semble pour eux
perdu d'avancé
on devrait connaître les premiers
résultats dans les prochains jours le
grand format de ce vendredi nous emmène
en inde là bas les femmes sont toujours
victimes de discrimination et
d'agression la raison essentielle une
culture machiste ancestrales et bien
dans la région de l'outarde pradesh
l'une des régions les plus pauvres du
pays là où les violences
on les plus exacerbées un groupe de
femmes a décidé de se révolter
on les appelle le gang des femmes en
rose grand format signe arnauld miguet
et dominique marault tel regarder on
n'imagine pas forcément une indienne en
sari maniant le bâton
pourtant dans cette région pauvre du
nord de l'inde ces femmes ont pris les
armes
littéralement voici le gang des gulabi à
l'entraînement comprenez le gang rose
des femmes qui défraie la chronique
depuis qu'elles ont décidé de prendre
leur destin en main ce qui ne plaît pas
à tout le monde
tirez vous d'ici banques n'y a rien et
c'est exactement cela qu'elles
combattent machisme mariage forcé
violences conjugales mais aussi
corruption l'intimidation de la part des
autorités qui ce jour là sans raison
apparente ont arrêté le mari de l'une
d'elles notre combat ne fait que
commencer
nous allons nous battre même s'il nous
met en prison et où pendent on ne
s'arrêtera pas à voter oui pour oeil
dent pour dent c'est justicière ansari
n'y vont pas de main morte pour traquer
épouse indigne et commis six policiers
véreux
un groupe créé il ya deux ans par cette
femme sans pattes balle 46 ans véritable
égérie qu est seul espoir pour que c'est
au filet face enfin entendre leur joie
expulsées de chez elles sans raison
celle ci fait la grève de la faim
maintenant nous sommes issus de vingt
mille femmes en colère à travers le pays
et si ça continue nous pourrions même
renverser le gouvernement un monde
d'hommes où la condition féminine n'a
jamais été très enviable cinquante trois
viols par jours on ne compte pas non
plus le nombre d'infanticides quand le
bébé de sexe féminin alors à la tombée
du jour quand le gang des saris roses se
retrouve on refait le monde un monde où
être femme ne serait pas considérée
comme une malédiction
ce combat contre la discrimination c'est
parce qu'ici on aborde quand on attend
une fille ça va coûter cher au moment de
la mariée une dot c jusqu'à vingt mille
euros
l'un des seuls pays au monde où il ya
plus d'hommes que de femmes et sans
pattes pâle fait des émules partout dans
le pays
désormais à lécousse de sa complice un
petit retour en arrière dans l'actualité
de la semaine avec cette image
impressionnante de la tempête qui a
frappé l'espagne ces derniers jours
gardé cette gigantesque déferlante qui
s'est abattue sur le bord de mer frais
du port de la corogne dans le nord-ouest
du pays rassurez vous pour les piétons
et les automobilistes plus de peur que
de mal
personne n'a été blessé
le chiffre est édifiant plus de 9
millions 500 mille points ont été
retirés l'an dernier des permis en
france ce sont essentiellement les excès
de vitesse et l'usagé du téléphone
portable au volant qui sont en tête des
infractions relevées mais alors
savez-vous aujourd'hui vraiment combien
de points il vous reste sur votre permis
la question mérite vous allez le voir
d'être posée car l'administration elle
même n'a pas toujours la bonne réponse
diego garcia pascal caron carton rose
pour ce producteur
combien de points durs est-il exactement
sur son permis il ne le sait pas en dix
ans il a commis pas mal d'infraction et
pour faire le point rien de tel qu'un
passage à la préfecture
et donc là vous aimez l'histoire
je suis très surpris parce qu'enfin je
m'aperçois que au lieu de trois points
et brest 9 mon permis a été recrédité 12
points plusieurs fois au bout de trois
ans alors même que dans cette période de
trois ans j'avais commis des infractions
qui normalement m'enlever des points
supplémentaires
vous y comprenez quelque chose pas
dangereusement difficile en effet de
comprendre quelque chose dans ce
chassé-croisé incessant entre point
débiter et recapitalisation un système
qui n'est pas sans rappeler celui des
banques pour la préfecture de police sur
votre compte bancaire
vous vous relevez que certaines dépenses
que vous avez fait il y a plusieurs
semaines n'ont pas encore été débités et
d'autres que vous avez fait l'avant
veille où la veille même le sont déjà
et bien c'est un peu pareil pour le
décompte des points en décortiquant se
relever notre producteur a mieux compris
pourquoi ils ne voyaient pas clair
comment s'y retrouver en effet lorsque
le retrait de points n'est effectif que
plusieurs mois après la date de
l'infraction
je les infractions que j'avais commises
n'était effectivement enregistrés qui
après douze treize quatorze parfois
jusqu'à 18 mois après la date effective
de l'infraction c'est une agréable
surprise dans mon cas mais j'imagine que
ça doit aussi fonctionner à l inverse
pour d'autres automobilistes
au final donc une gestion désastreuse
des points de permis en cause le
matériel vétuste de l'administration une
administration qui n'est pas tenu à un
délai pour appliquer le retrait de
points mais il ya mieux d'après cet
avocat spécialisé
ce fichier du permis de conduire est
gérée par trois instances à savoir les
services fiscaux et services de police
et les services de la justice et c'est
trois instances se télescopent et en
fonction de la procédure de
l'automobiliste vous arrivez à des
délais de procédure et d'application du
retrait de points qui peuvent être plus
ou moins long l'an dernier 9 millions de
points ont été retirés et 90000
automobilistes privés du permis de
conduire sport cela devait être une
tournée comme beaucoup d'autres l'équipe
de football de cuba se déplace en ce
moment aux états unis afin de tenter de
se qualifier pour les jo de pékin
plusieurs rencontres au programme mais
l'entraîneur vient de se retrouver
confronté à un problème d'effectif sept
de ses joueurs ont disparu aaron transit
fiers comme des coqs ces footballeurs
cubain passer pour de grands patriotes
prêts à défendre les couleurs du pays
son idéologie sa révolution sur le sol
même des états unis
direction la floride et son tournoi
qualificatif pour les prochains jeux
olympiques et devant les caméras cubaine
il déclarait avec ferveur leur amour de
la nation
nous porterons avec amour les couleurs
de notre drapeau
nous allons entrer dans les profondeurs
du monstre américain et nous en portons
avec nous l'esprit de la révolution
cubaine dans les rues de miami et virage
à 180 degrés à peine arrivée sur le sol
américain sept joueurs de l'est qui
prennent la poudre d'escampette et
organismes d'une conférence de presse
pendant ce temps leurs anciens
coéquipiers jouent à dix contre onze
face au honduras et perdre le match
c'est douloureux d'abandonner l'équipe
les joueurs vont nous manquer pas
tellement les entraîneurs nous avons
pris cette décision notre famille ne
doit pas en payer les conséquences
nous ne sommes pas inquiets au pays ses
joueurs passent maintenant pour des
traîtres
reste que ce genre de défection n'est
pas rare l'année dernière six autres
sportifs
ces trois boxeurs exilé en allemagne ou
encore ce handballeur au brésil ont
profité de compétitions à l'étranger
pour déserter les entraîneurs fut bains
sont indignés
c'est une trahison un drapeau et à toute
une nation à cuba si le sport est roi
il se pratique dans des gymnases
vétustes et toujours de façon amateur
c'est la loi voulue par fidel castro
depuis 1962 qu'on sait sportif s'exiler
à l'étranger donc devenue une aubaine
n'en déplaise à fidel sport toujours eu
et ils seront bien sur le terrain demain
après midi sur france 2 le tournoi des
six nations connaîtra son épilogue la
france se déplace au pays de galles les
gallois qui joueront pour le grand
chelem
les bleus pour le remporter le tournoi
elles devront quant à eux s'imposer très
largement le point avec manuel tissier
julien bénéteau et bruno vignais une
fois de plus les bleus jouent gros
au pays de galles six mois après le
quart de finale contre les all blacks le
toit du millennium stadium abritera
demain la finale du tournoi 2008
tout à l'heure les tricolores ont
retrouvé avec plaisir cette enceinte
bénisse
mais demain soir ils n'auront pas à
affronter la menace de 15 néo zélandais
mais la pression de 70000 gallois om
pression mais ça c'est pas ça peut pas
être tout le temps négatif ça peut être
aussi positif ça peut nous justement
nous nous resserrer comme ça c'était
passé un peu comme pour le cas finale
des blacks c'est à dire que on a senti
une équipe de france soudée unie et qui
a démontré des valeurs qui lui est
propre au rugby français
pour ce cinquième et dernier match
les sélectionneurs ont voulu s'appuyer
sur l'expérience et le poids des anciens
après avoir testé 37 joueurs marc
lièvremont a rappellé call car le pays
de galles fait peur les diables rouges
ont gagné en angleterre et en irlande
ils n'ont encaissé que deux essais et
pour remporter le tournoi la france doit
non seulement s'imposer mais surtout le
faire avec 20 points d'écart humble et
lucide
les bleus font donc profil bas
n'ayant pas la prétention de dire qu'on
va les gagner le tour parce que je pense
que c'est ça sera très délicat 20 points
se marquent pas comme ça mais les
perspectives ne sont pas forcément aussi
sombre que le ciel de cardiff les
français ont gagné tous leurs matchs
contre les gallois depuis sept ans en
marquant au moins deux essais et sachets
pour la note que demain sera apparemment
divisé au sein du couple fignon puisque
si le premier ministre sera supporters
des bleus son épouse originaires du pays
dial a confié à un quotidien gallois
qu'elle soutiendrait son pays
football on connaît les affiches des
quarts de finale de la ligue des
champions
des chocs sans club français mais avec
quatre clubs anglais arsenal sera
d'ailleurs opposé à liverpool manchester
à la roma chelsea à fenerbahçe enfin le
barça des tirs et henry au club allemand
de schalke 04
sachez que ce matin au salon du livre le
prix essai france télévisions était
décerné à wassyla tamzali pour une
éducation algérienne au récit d'un
parcours personnel dans l'algérie post
coloniale jusqu'à aujourd'hui en passant
par les années noires du terrorisme
islamiste
un livre édité chez gallimard avant de
terminer journal je vous rappelle l'une
des principales informations du jour
avec la répression chinoise au tibet
plusieurs pays occidentaux dont
notamment les états unis et l'union
européenne ont appelé pékin à la retenue
et au respect de la culture tibétaine un
message relayé aujourd'hui par le chef
spirituel tibétain en exil le dalaï lama
la pression concernant les droits de
l'homme se confirme sur les autorités
chinoises et cela à cinq mois des jeux
olympiques de l'été prochain voilà pour
l'actualité de ce vendredi merci pour
votre fidélité je vous donne rendez vous
demain à 13h pour 30 minutes
d'information avec votre magazine dès
13h15 dans l'instant la météo isabelle
martinez puis le point route valérie
maurice boulevard du palais en première
partie de soirée puis le livre et son
salon dans esprit libre avec guillaume
durand bien sûr très belle soirée à vous
et à demain
l'info en continu et a dit sur france 2
pourrait faire